[Music]
finally back
in the middle of the action
[Applause]
football fans from across europe are
coming together beer is flowing
and all of it is happening without face
masks as if nothing ever happened
we are worried about the delta variant
the delta variant means we have to stay
cautious
the delta variant is coming it spreads
faster than previous variants
so is the party over should europe be
back
on a crisis footing is the vaccine
rollout not fast enough
what's the verdict for europe is the
glass half empty
or half full hello and welcome to dw's
covert 19 special i'm daniel winter
in berlin delta delta plus even a gamma
a veritable alphabet soup of coronavirus
variants
let's take a closer look at delta which
originated in india
it spreads faster than the original in
europe it's becoming the predominant
strain
delta accounts for 97 of all sequenced
positive test samples in the uk
and is blamed for sending infections
rising once again
it's also dominant in portugal and
russia elsewhere the variant is
spreading quickly in austria where it
represents
one of every two cases and it's getting
a foothold in the czech republic too
in germany recent data shows delta is
around 37 percent
of new infections but the country's
infectious disease center recently
estimated
it was already higher perhaps 50 percent
some predict the delta variant could
account for 90 percent of all new cases
by the end of august
that may sound bad but remember there's
no evidence that the disease is
any more dangerous the scientific
evidence shows the spread of delta is
cause for caution
but not for panic
getting the first shot of a vaccine
against 19 is likely to come as a big
relief to those lucky enough to have one
but what happens when new variants come
along
the world of science has some good news
on this front
against the delta variant biontech was
found to be 88
effective at preventing symptomatic
disease
that's according to a study by public
health england
astrazeneca was 60 effective
as for the delta plus variant not enough
data is available to know how it
interacts with immunizations
scientists in india and worldwide are
looking into it
but researchers say it's unlikely it'll
outfox the current jabs
as well as the vaccine's effectiveness
against the variants
another big question is how long the
shots protect us for
according to a nature paper it could be
a good while
that's for mrna jabs like biontech
moderna
the figure of the immune response found
in some biotech
vaccinated people was said by
researchers to be a strong indication
that protection could last for years
that's against covid19 as it looks at
the moment
if the virus changes out of all
recognition it might be a different ball
game
but that may or may not happen in the
future
for now the vaccines available are our
best way out of this pandemic
[Applause]
and joining us now is dr andreas
bergtala a
virologist at the austrian academy of
sciences
so alpha beta gamma
epsilon delta and delta plus even now
how worried do we need to be about all
these variants
i don't know whether word is the right
word i would say we have to be alert
because we know that the virus keeps
changing this is something we have been
observing since the beginning of the
pandemic and we do know that there are
certain variants which have become more
infectious
um sometimes also acquiring immune
escape properties so evading the immune
response a bit better
and these are all properties that one
has to factor
in when we try to counter the virus by
for example
particular measurements such as social
distancing
or vaccination and why is it that we're
now suddenly hearing about so many
variants showing up are they
really just coming to light just now are
we just starting to understand them more
what's the case there i think it's a
very interesting question that
um science itself and the scientists i
think don't fully
understand yet what is clear is that
many of these variants they actually
take quite some time until the surface
so just to give you one example
delta has been first sequenced in
september 2020.
so it took more than half a year for
this virus to eventually
hit the uk and eventually now also rest
of continental europe and the world
and so this is one thing it takes time
for these variants
at the same time also we have evidence
that we see over the last
months that evolution might be
accelerating so that somehow
sarskoff ii might be faster
in acquiring mutations and these are all
processes that scientists try to
understand better
okay and uh looking at what the possible
near future could be
dealing with all of these variants the
uk says that they're aiming for total
unlocking
on june the 19th but delta case numbers
are still very high so
is this the right thing to do in your
opinion now do we just have to accept
that there is going to be no
good time to unlock and just grit our
teeth and get through it
i mean to cite some well-known
scientists in the uk uh
this is going to be a big experiment and
it's always
i think difficult or impossible to to
know up front
what's going to happen but i think
chances are that this will
lead to a big spike in increase of
infections
and the question is how much will this
affect hospitalization rate
and and severe cases of of of clinical
disease
and we do know that in general uh the
current
uh vaccines including astrosenica that
is used wide in the uk but also biotech
for example has
a very high protection against severe
disease
and this is something i think that one
has to see since there's still
a quite a big share of the population
including the younger ones
that have been not vaccinated whether
this experiment turns out to be the
right way
right well i'd just like to pick up on
that actually you know israeli
researchers just recently have said
that the biontech jab is less effective
against the delta variant than
previously thought which is what
i guess you were referring to there what
does this mean for the fight against
covert 19
i think one has to distinguish between
uh the different effects of
of being vaccinated on the one hand a
vaccine is there to protect yourself
so it's kind of an egoistic action
and this is still giving you a very high
protection
against the delta variant the other
point is
you would like to have a vaccine to
prevent the spread of the virus so
from being infected in the first place
and then transmitting the virus to other
persons
and there seems to be uh some data
coming from israel
that maybe those people have been
vaccinated with biotech quite some time
ago already
and this is also important to factor in
time
that those people might still get
infected although
they don't succumb to the disease or
develop severe disease so
i think overall there's still good news
that the vaccines are working against
delta
but it could be that they are not as
effective anymore in reducing the spread
so um are we kind of wasting our time
with too much alarmism around the
variants
um i'm not sure i think we should not be
surprised anymore after one and a half
years of the pandemic um that there will
be new variants coming
uh around and whether it's delta epsilon
lambda
um the greek alphabet has 24 letters so
let's see when we reach omega
but i think these are things that we can
expect the big question with all of
these
new arriving variants is do they have
changed properties are they more
infectious do they lead to more
disease are they potentially escaping
uh the immune response speed is from
natural infection or also from
vaccination okay
and this is something i guess that has
to be um
assessed for each and every very
absolutely important questions
for the future for us to ask there dr
andreas bergtala of the austrian academy
of sciences thank you very much for
joining us
thank you for having me and it's not
just
us who ask the questions now it's your
turn it's the part of the program where
we put
one of your questions to our science
correspondent derek williams
does the vaccine block the virus or
simply keep it from causing severe
disease
okay i've talked about this several
times in the past but maybe it's time
for an update on
on what we know now as you rightly point
out mark
initial trials carried out with vaccines
that have been approved for use so far
they were set up to look at the vaccine
safety and how well the vaccines were
able to block the development
of symptomatic disease in recipients
in particular severe disease and and
they're really
really good at that though they're not
perfect what are called
breakthrough cases do occur those are
people
who are fully vaccinated that somehow
subsequently
test positive for the virus but when you
look at the numbers
breakthrough infections are few and far
between
and most of the people it happens to
get asymptomatic or mild cases
of covet breakthrough cases that end up
in the hospital
are even fewer and and far betweener
if you can say that so a big win
on the primary goal of stopping bad
disease
but it's taken time to gather data on a
major
secondary goal which is stopping virus
transmission
do vaccines also provide at least some
degree of what's called
sterilizing immunity that's when
if you're exposed to a pathogen after
getting your shots
your immune system is so primed to wipe
it out that the pathogen basically has
no chance
to gain even a temporary foothold
and since it can't replicate in you you
can't give it to someone else
evidence is now piling up that if you're
vaccinated
then your risk of catching covet 19
in a measurable way is a lot lower
so the logical assumption is that the
chances you might subsequently pass it
along
are also a lot lower than they would be
for someone who is
unvaccinated but a small chance
isn't a zero chance the fact page at
johns hopkins university expresses
our current level of knowledge very well
i think
it says vaccines are
likely to reduce the risk of virus
transmission but
probably not completely for everyone
[Music]
and that's all for this edition of our
covert 19 special for more information
about the pandemic you can check out the
covert 19 section
on our website dw.com i'm daniel winter
in berlin until next time thanks for
watching and take care
[Music]